larry fink of blackrock shared a lot of
thoughts recently and boy oh boy are
they pretty wild now remember blackrock
is one of the largest asset managers in
the world they've got about 10 trillion
dollars in assets under management and
ultimately what they have been talking
about is everything from thoughts around
the fact that russia invaded ukraine is
likely to mark the end of globalization
but also they've been talking a lot
about bitcoin cryptocurrencies central
bank digital currencies and that's what
i want to talk to you about today what
we know is that blackrock is now taking
a look at bitcoin cryptocurrencies and
other types of these technologies due to
increased interest from clients now
remember blackrock is a massive massive
business blackrock has about 16 000
employees over 85 offices in 38
countries they are the world's largest
asset manager and that assets under
management is around 10 trillion dollars
in a recent letter to shareholders he
said to our shareholders and then you
dig deep deep deep into this letter and
you find a very interesting paragraph
where he stated finally a let's discuss
aspect of the war is its potential
impact on accelerating digital
currencies the war has prompted
countries to re-evaluate their currency
dependencies he then says the u.s
central bank for example recently
launched a study to examine the
potential implications of a u.s digital
dollar and he also said that digital
currencies can help bring down costs of
cross-border payments for example when
ex-patriot workers send earnings back to
their families as we see increasing
interest from our clients blackrock is
studying digital currencies stable coins
and the underlying technologies to
understand how they can help us serve
our clients but of course larry fink
doesn't think it's all positive he also
went on to say that he believes that
this has exasperated the polarization
and extremist behavior we are seeing
across society today as bitcoiners have
been saying for years now
doesn't matter what they say they can be
billionaires they can be large asset
managers they can be your neighbor down
the street publicly traded companies or
a financial institution they all are
going to capitulate bitcoin is good for
business crypto is good for business the
world's largest asset manager is now
telling their clients we hear you we
know you're interested we see the demand
we are doing our homework and we are
going to get in the game 10 trillion
dollars assets under management the big
question is what percent of that is
going to be in bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies in the future hey you
did you like this video great we make
five of them a day and post them here on
this channel make sure you subscribe
like the video and see you next time